when you think about that draft class of
ham and edwards
man there's a lot of talent coming to
the league right now
yeah i mean you look at
you know just across the board you think
about anthony edwards you think about
lamello and those are like generational
type players
you know
and and with generational type
confidence because i think shaq talks
about
you have to have a certain personality
and a certain confidence to be able to
be successful in the league yeah they're
they're both
and ant-man and lamelo are fighting to
be the face of the league
these two guys have potential to be the
face of our league and they're both they
both have the confidence to say it
and they have the talent to back it up
and do it so it's going to be amazing to
see these guys grow i'll be watching
closely closely not afraid for your
first pick what's your first pick oh
first pick what mellow or the first leg
huh can't answer that okay wow once you
pick like you pick your ties just close
your eyes
i'm not wearing the tie so what are you
talking about
giannis
he's the face of the league right now oh
you're laughing at his jokes